So, how would you describe your feelings without using the word "love?"
Without using the word "love?"
When they say that two become one?
We've really done that.
And that just says it all.
He's part of me.
He really is part of me.
I can't imagine myself without him, which is scary but real.
She is everything.
I can tell that he loves me because I can see it in his eyes,...
...and I can tell in the way we talk to each other, the way we relate to each other.
What do you see in his eyes when you look at each other?
I see me in his eyes.
I'm grateful for what you do and I'm grateful for who you are.
When all is said and done and all the music is gone and the noise is gone,...
...and the conversations are gone, there's still that bond between us.
And that's the best way I can describe it.